our shelters and immigration facilities
are of course totally overrun
and if title 42 expires this week and
remember the Biden Administration does
not want they want it to expire they
want it gone the tool the the tool out
of the toolbox
the flow of illegals will surge to 14
000 every single day if not more
here now with more on this crisis live
in La Jolla Texas Fox News contributor
Sarah Carter you've done great reporting
throughout what do you have tonight
thank you so much feet well you know
several hours ago the Department of
Justice actually submitted to the
Supreme Court an appeal to basically
extend title 42 for probably just a week
or so to give the White House just
enough time to figure out what they're
going to do with this border chaos eat
and I can tell you this that while
they're debating on how to handle the
U.S Mexico border and the millions that
are going to come pouring across it's
the people here in McAllen Texas in La
Jolla and all along the border that
really have to deal with the enormous
amount of people and strain on their
resources we were out early today with
Texas Department of Public Safety as
well as border patrol as people were
bailing out of vehicles into residential
neighborhoods literally jumping over
fences into gated communities we were
running behind their homes in some cases
I even looked in as people were eating
breakfast as they were searching for
runners behind in the houses it's it's
extraordinarily frustrating not only for
law enforcement but obviously for the
people in these communities we also
attended today it was a town hall
meeting with both Democrats and
Republicans alike both wondering when
the Biden Administration the federal
government was actually going to do its
job to protect the border and I had an
opportunity to speak with congresswoman
Monica De La Cruz here this is her
district and she is extraordinarily
frustrated she says this is a bipartisan
effort that people in her community are
angry and they want some change and they
want it now take a listen to what she
had to say
who's really benefiting from having no
regulations or laws at the border the
only one that's benefiting right now is
the cartel they're charging these
immigrants 10 15 20 000 to bring them
through the Southern Southern border
they're also benefiting because of the
amount of drugs that they're able to
pass through our borders so the only
person of persons who are winning are
the cartel why does it appear that the
administration is then supporting the
cartels and human traffickers have you
brought this up to the White House have
you said hey wait a minute we might
disagree on a few things but I think we
could agree on this look we obviously
don't agree agree on a lot of things one
being that I believe we need to put the
policies of remain in Mexico in back in
place stopped the catch and release
program and title 42 needs to continue
until we have immigration reform and
legislation where we can streamline the
process and have immigrants wait in
Mexico or go to Safe countries where
they can apply for the Asylum process
what would your message be to President
Biden right now about how urgent a
crisis is and what he needs to do to
stop it I invite President Biden to come
down to South Texas and see for his own
eyes what is happening to talk to these
brave men and women in Border Patrol and
Customs that are at the front lines
seeing this what is about to happen when
title 42 is lifted will be a catastrophe
of epic proportions
well it is a catastrophe Pete right
across the border in Mexico there are
now just right here several miles from
us more than 10
000 people that are waiting to make a
move across the border under title 42.
just before we got on the air there were
a number of people that came across the
border mainly children these were
illegal migrants that crossed over we
had one border patrol agent trying to
process all of them right now just down
the road from me there is a bus here uh
it is filled with the migrants I talked
to a girl as young as 10 years old who
traveled with her teenage brother all
the way from El Salvador to here and it
was a very harrowing journey I gotta
tell you Pete it's heartbreaking when
you talk to the people and when you
realize how abused they are on this
journey to the United States and I asked
them why did they take the chance why
are you coming this way I mean you're so
young weren't you afraid and she said
yes but I haven't seen my mother in five
years and I want to find my family and a
lot of times these children are abused
and sometimes like you said and you
reported earlier they're with abusers
and I can't get them to talk about
everything but it is really it was a
really tragic situation here along the
border
wow sir I can't help but think you know
wanting to see your family is very
admirable it's not necessarily a
qualification for Asylum which is what
which is what makes it illegal and and
and
right that's where the abuse of the
system comes in and where the tens of
thousands are added yes go ahead
right and many times uh P many times
these children are are trained to say
the story the way that they say it uh
many times they're with people that have
traveled with them that have prepared
them to enter into the country this way
and just like you reported last night a
lot of these children are abused once
they enter the United States and we
honestly do not have the resources uh to
handle this and this is why you're
seeing this breakdown in our system and
a breakdown here at the border and by
this weekend the temperatures are going
to drop into the low 20s and they're
expecting some very dangerous situations
so they're expecting quite a few people
to try in the next couple of nights but
they're also very concerned here border
patrol and law enforcement that some
children and other adults may lose their
life on their attempt to try to come
into the United States
cartels and lies of deception and seeing
those images you brought us of a border
patrol agents going through beautiful
neighborhoods uh that's what it's come
to Sarah thank you so much hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else